oh well
if you're watching this from the future
congratulations you found this and
congratulations you've accomplished all
of your objectives and all of your
dreams and all of your goals and I'm
very proud of you very proud of you for
doing that
um but in the meantime
I have
so much ahead of me that I need to do
hi yes hello welcome
um
you've been busy you've been so busy out
there you've been so incredibly busy
hard work just busy bees you know just
worker bees droning on
getting things done and I'm proud of you
proud of you
you're really dug deep you know
you see any challenge in front of you
and you think it's nothing for me
if I just keep at it you know any
mountain can be climbed as what you
think
persistence
oh there's
hi yes
um I'm here
uh
oh look at all of you here just as if
you're gonna hear something that you
wanna hear no aren't you just aren't you
just so eager aren't you just so eager
aren't you just so goddamn eager
oh look at all of you Josh crawling out
of the woodwork you guys to so like
termites you know
crumbling the foundation of of whatever
you set your mind to and that's that's
really what is that's really uh that's
really what it's all about that's really
what it's all about
um nothing but good things coming up God
why are I literally
it's almost like you're expecting me to
say something almost like you're
expecting me to tell you something
almost like you're expecting me to just
like confirm something that you've been
oh you've been well I'm
salivating for for so long
like you're in the Des the desert and
you know you got like um no water around
you're just so thirsty you know all you
can think about is that water you know
the water is all you can think about hey
[Laughter]
fine
[Music]
I admit it
I'll admit
here
on this stream
in front of everybody live
the U
[Music]
H have met my requirements
I will make an old events
is that what you wanted is that what you
want is that what you wanted you sick
twisted individuals yeah okay I'll do it
I didn't think you know I didn't think
that um people would be this ravenous
about it
um I didn't have it prepared you know
I'm gonna I'm not gonna lie I didn't
have it prepared beforehand
um not that I didn't think you'd do it
but you know how it is with these things
they take ah time and planning and I I
got to get the URL I gotta contact only
fans get the URL okay I can't be just
like the real Markiplier oh one on only
fans no I gotta get my actual one which
I don't have yet
um because I didn't
God you guys are so happy you guys are
so happy and I'm so happy for you I'm so
happy for you did you Jersey like
okay why are it's why what is wrong with
any of you what is wrong with all of you
I set out impossible requirements I set
out literally impossible requirements
literally impossible ones
[Music]
no Mark you're a YouTuber so much more
than that it is it's like it's not even
I told you what it's gonna be I think I
think a lot of you are what do you think
I'm gonna ask you what do you think that
the only fans content is going to be
about I want to hear it I want to hear
this because if I don't I'm not 100 I
know some of you are like no how could
this be well you didn't prevent it
because the Avalanche of people that
were in favor of it were just like
sprinting to the finish line but what do
you think that it's going to be what do
you what do you think
God
what did I say what did I say that it
would be right and and you can go back
you can go back and you can you can you
can see what it was what I said it was
gonna be it's not it's not that
no no no I said I said tasteful
tasteful nudes I said tasteful I said
very tasteful right I said extremely
tasteful nudes like what I've done
before therefore the definition of what
that was wouldn't change from them to
now you know what I mean it wouldn't
have changed for in the interim time
right I don't know when some people got
this idea that I would just be like full
frontal like just staring into the
camera I don't eye tracking uncensored
I mean I guess you're right I could
technically post videos of gameplay that
I've played without the censorship but
that would put lyxian out of a job and I
I don't want to do that I don't want to
do that to him oh why is this scary
music so goddamn loud
I'm trying to get back to I was supposed
to do a lot of Halloween stuff uh but
things got sidetracked okay you're okay
guys please no I said what one thing of
what it was going to be I said one thing
of what it was going to be and your
disappointment is immeasurable and that
is not my concern I said what was gonna
be I don't know why you thought it would
be anything else I don't think I don't
think
why would I wear lingerie
why would I wear lingerie look you if
you have and some of you do if someone
you own my tasteful nudes calendar you
will have an expectation of what it
would be and that's what it would be now
that being said now that being said
a
Witnesses I don't know what you were
expecting but there will be an only fans
and let's just say
maybe once I create the only fans maybe
it will awaken something within me a
deep yearning need but but I have a
sense of of taste of taste there now uh
I do also want to talk about it
you got you you
came for you got what you came for you
uh but that being said I I am aware that
I have been away uh from YouTube for a
bit I will tell you why why I've been
away from YouTube for a bit made of
listen this isn't requests this isn't
requests and usually I don't take
requests but feel free to spam your
requests if you
if you sh so feel
um
but uh I have been away for a little bit
for uh like I haven't uploaded normal
content before the only fans uh
extravaganza
but I do want to say thank you for
checking out distractible and go my
favorite sports team and thank you for
there's a link in the description for it
as well thank you for signing up uh to
watch my mom's documentary that did mean
a lot to me um and it means even more to
my mom and if you don't show up there on
November 13th and if you don't know what
I'm talking about then you better look
in the description below because if you
don't know what I'm talking about then
you didn't pay attention to the
requirements and many of you did meet
the new requirements but there's always
opportunity for more because my mom is
my mom and therefore I would do anything
for my mom including making an only fans
and so I am I am a man of my word I'm a
word I'm a man of my word is that the
express I'm I say what I mean to say all
the time I've never not said something
that I mean to have said at a moment
therefore the only fans will be a
reality but
I have been away and I'm coming back and
I'm getting back into regular videos
because apparently slap slap the tip on
the camera
usually this wouldn't you can't just
write [ __ ] like that on the internet you
can't do that someone's someone's gonna
someone's gonna be mad someone's gonna
be upset about that you can't just say
that
you think the anonymity of the internet
is going to protect you don't say such
things
I don't even know what you said someone
else yeah you're gonna read it anyway so
I've been away because I've been working
on something and I have not made it a
secret unless I have made it a secret in
which case I probably shouldn't not say
that it's not a secret I've been working
on finishing up uh or helping to finish
up the edge of sleep the TV show and if
you don't know what the edge of sleep is
what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you but anyway so the
edge of sleep TV show
um I have been
balls deep in that edit I guess that's
the mood that's that's the vibe of this
livestream thing is anyway uh so I've
been knee deep in that one
um and it is like something that I'm
very excited about I've been talking
about it
um for some time in very vague terms but
it is becoming a reality
um as the uh show gets
finished up and it is I'm very happy
with how it is and I'm very excited
about it and I will have more to say
about that very soon but there's still a
little bit more work to be done on the
show and then when it's done you guys
will see it on uh some
like this is my ambition at this time
and it's not a guarantee with any of
these things but on some streaming
platform of
definite Renown and it will be a
wonderful thing because uh it is an
actual TV show which you know judging by
the traditional definitions of these
traditional definitions of these things
you know
I've made many things that could qualify
but this is wonderful please be Netflix
I have I will talk to them I'll get them
on the phone right now I don't really
this is my this is my experience about
that world is I don't often know how
these things work
um but I can't imagine that it's much
different than me picking up the phone
and being like hey how about I do this
thing that's what I want to do about the
the Five Nights of Freddy's movie you
know they're actually making that I
don't think that I can call up Mr
blumhouse himself uh and be like hey put
me in the movie I I could I could be
whoever you need me to be
I could dispense ice cream from my
fingertips my make blue I was the
balloons from the fingertips I don't
think squirting ice cream from your
fingertips might not be the best
superpower
but was it inflating I don't even
remember tweet him I guess that is the
2022 equivalent of picking up the phone
and calling somebody but no I would love
to be that's the thing I would love to
be and the thing is I can act I actually
can I'm not I'm not bullshitting about
that I've made some of you cry with my
acting before and I know it and I I do
it and as soon as the edge of sleep
comes out then I can prove it but no one
knows that because no none of the people
that I would pick up the phone because
they don't have Twitter or whatever
would know that but I'm like me I'm the
guy I'm king of Five Nights at Freddy's
I'm that guy you there's a YouTube's
coming out of me king oh my God I was
supposed to promote that
[Music]
I'm running out of chips to promote
things oh [ __ ]
um right there's a YouTube's coming out
that's uh me king of Five Nights at
Freddy's unless I wasn't supposed to say
that yet
that's a secret
oh
frick
um
is that out yet
I don't know what's what's the point of
even a secret it doesn't matter what
does it matter what is the secrets
matter do Secrets matter Secrets don't
matter it doesn't matter anyway so if
I'm not in the Five Nights at Freddy's
movie what does that even mean
I'm I'm the guy
I can be purple
I could be purple
I could be purple
I could definitely be purple
did I spoil it
[ __ ] well it's not it's not a secret
it's I don't know I don't have a link
for it you gotta find it for yourself
I don't know it's it's it's pretty cool
I guess
it could be purple I could
be purple
I could do that I could be purple yeah I
could do that
anyway
that'd be nice
it's not a secret anymore exactly it's a
it's a reveal it's dramatic it builds
hype that's how it works just like the
eventual reveal that I'll be in the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie and not a cameo
fashion that's what I don't want you
know I've been offered Cameo rolls and
stuff before and it's like that's not
what I don't want not that I'm like
against cameos but I'm I I can actually
act I can and I could I can prove it I
can prove it just go to the end of in
space with markiplier I can [ __ ]
prove it I've I've acted plenty
anyway so I I'm getting to that point in
my career where I'm kind of just like I
stop really asking nicely I'm just I'm
in the same way that I deal with Brands
and companies right I just kind of like
uh uh I kind of like do whatever I want
whenever I want and I could just be like
no shut up I'm not just a YouTuber and
there's nothing wrong with being just a
YouTuber
let me just photos sir please calm down
you're right I'm sorry we're getting a
little stressed here I actually have a a
special treat for you that I'm going to
be playing in a little bit something
that you have not seen probably probably
a lot of you have not seen this or if
you have not seen it it has been an
extremely long time since the last time
you would even have thought of this
thing
um but I'm gonna be playing that now I'm
going to try to get through the entirety
of it because I know I've been away for
a very long time and for some reason I
have avoided or I I didn't even avoid it
I didn't mean to avoid it right so
here's another spoiler of something I
probably shouldn't have said I was
trying this month oh this month I was
trying to get out uh three scary games
episode 100 right I was trying to work
up to that because it was it was perfect
there was only like where what 94 and it
was like oh cool do a big thing on
Halloween it'll be three scary games
100. and then I got busy editing the
edge of sleep the TV show
not that I edited all of it I'm not even
taking I'm not taking credit for any of
it it's really just like I'm helping to
finish it up so I'm trying to like
tweak it a bit anyway just like make it
as good as it could be because I am a
good editor I'm not saying I'm better
than anyone this really sounds like I'm
trying to say that I'm better than
anyone which is not the case I'm just
trying to help I want projects to be
good and if I have any ability to help
it be good I take that ability to help
it be good even if it means that I don't
sleep at all
yeah
so anyway what was I saying something
rather important
anyway
I'm actually am I actually in it or am I
helping produce it what the edge of
sleep
I'm I'm the star I'm I'm the lead I'm
I'm the lead guy I'm in it I'm the guy
you're gonna see a thing yeah you're
gonna see a thing all right you're gonna
see a thing on my only event it'll be
the first it'll be the first TV show to
premiere on only
that'll be what it is yeah God it's so
funny because in edge of sleep the
character's name is Dave and you guys
remember Wilford mother loving more
stash was one of my favorite things I
just like constantly in my head I've
gone Dave Dave that's just like the
wharf section
Dave
Greg Steve
Dave
just like for some reason ever ever the
name that pops up in my head whenever
I'm writing something it's always Dave
and so for this movie that I'm writing
uh that's a secret
um this movie that I'm writing uh like
so I just place it the character's name
is Dave and everyone's just Dave like
whenever
yeah do they have someone exclaimed Dave
to you [ __ ] all the time in the show
damn
but you know I hate to say it but
warfstash does not make an appearance in
the edge of sleep although I would love
to sneak an Easter egg in there but I
don't think that anyone would be with
people with that
I would love to God I would love to but
man there's all the the Riders and the
producers would be mad at me but it is
what it is anyway so it's very exciting
anyway no reference today no I mean
everyone shouts Dave but whatever it is
what it is so anyway uh to recap uh
about to play a game that you haven't
seen in a while
um only fans yes thank you for
supporting my own depravity enabling it
enabling my depravity
and then Edge sleep TV show I've been
working on that coming back to normal
videos okay
oh Five Nights at Freddy's movie I want
to I would do a great job I will
audition I will do the whole shebang
think of how think about cohesive that I
think just think of it think of think of
how that would work think of how that
would work that would work it would work
amazing hashtag
Markiplier in the FNAF movie it would
work so good it would work oh [ __ ]
think of it God
could be acting right now you'd never
know you've never I'm that good
it could be purple right now you never
know rub off this makeup
purple underneath
I'm not wearing makeup
maybe I should
maybe I should
is that normalized yet
men wearing makeup I could do that I
could do it
or it could be purple
they make purple makeup
I don't even know the lore that's that's
the terrible thing like I I call myself
the king of Five Nights at Freddy's I
don't even know the first thing I've
never read any of the books I've never
looked deeper into the lore I always
play every game that comes out and I'm
just like what is happening I have no
idea it's just like I've never had uh
like a deeper dive into the actual look
of it yeah
purple
is that the hashtag watch matpat oh
can't be bothered to do that those
there's so many FNAF videos that he's
made
there's so many for that videos I
couldn't possibly do that
there's such a there's such a mixture of
different messages being spammed in here
anyway so I'm gonna get into the game
um and like
you guys just calmed down
um
and uh we'll get into this
that was on the game
foreign
they made a
um
they made a
update of it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so this game
uh is night
this is Nightmare House 2. this is
Nightmare House too it's a game that
came out a very long time ago which is
great
very scary
it's extremely scary
and
it was I originally played it way back
on my channel and the very special thing
about this is I played it so early on my
channel that the audio is awful there
it's terrible
um because I recorded directly into
fraps I recorded directly into fraps
shut the [ __ ] up if shut the [ __ ] up
I recorded directly into fraps
and
I took that and just popped it into
premiere
and I went with that
okay all right now with Nightmare House
2 they made an update in yes fraps if
you remember
no I I know this is good this is really
old fraps is a very old software no I I
that's not I'm you're not hearing me
right
into frappus
fraps
traps focus on the fraps
focus on the fraps I recorded into that
and it it I did it doesn't matter
there's nightmares too
so if you're wondering
what the Nightmare House is oh wow there
it is holy [ __ ]
I might be in trouble
um
interesting so this is nightmares too
it's a it's a
I was about to say Five Nights at
Freddy's mod it is not a Five Nights at
Freddy's mod it is a half-life mod
and uh it's a wonderful
uh Half-Life mod where you
chop things
I'm gonna start over
this is gonna quit out of the game
foreign
[ __ ]
that's a start over everybody let's
let's start over
hey guys
here it is guys Nightmare House two I
know this is a blast from the past uh
we I look oh [ __ ] did you see that that
was spooky
yeah [ __ ]
I know it's so crazy right welcome to
nightmare house 2. now I have not played
this in a very long time and I'm super
happy to get back into it and I love
this game
but when I originally played it I
recorded it directly into fraps right so
if you don't know what fraps is it's a
very old recording thing that I don't
think has been updated even since like
2010 but it was what people use to
record gameplay a long time ago and when
I did it I recorded it directly into
fraps and then I popped that into
Premiere and
I didn't separate my audio from my
microphone from the audio of the game
therefore it was horrendously imbalanced
but this time
I'm gonna do it right and we're and this
is an updated version of the game
released in like 2015 that I'm going to
play and I'm going to enjoy the entire
experience because it's slightly
remastered and there might be some new
surprises in store for us new spooks
new anyway so
oh God that spooked me all right I'm
gonna go
thank you
all right I'm just gonna carry on
I uh
I had a separate
um
I was showing
changes that I made
can't get in here
oops and what do I do do I come around
I might actually be in [ __ ] huge
trouble
like I might actually be
am I actually
it's fine I'm gonna carry on
I'm gonna it's fine
I'm just gonna enjoy this one oh wow
that was surprising
okay
so
this is new I don't even remember it's
been so long since I played that I don't
know what's going to be new and what's
going to be old I played this anciently
like incredibly long ago I mean 10 years
which is an incredibly long time no
matter what how you say it like 10 years
ago is a very long time and it's like a
half-life uh two mod and it's a funny
thing where I know there's a lot of like
gmod horror maps these days that are
being made uh that have it it just has
this vibe to it right it has this weird
kind of like you know the game Grandma
it's got like that that vibe of
something okay
something being off
hello
I swear that didn't spook me
I don't even remember there being really
weapons back there no there were okay I
remember getting like a like a shotgun
or something oh I need that don't I
it's interesting I do think that this ax
is custom yeah that's right freaking
physics crap
ah
right I probably got stuck on that
puzzle I was not a good gamer I'm not
good now I don't even know if I qualify
as a gamer but I definitely was not that
good
oh
oh there we go we're in
oh I vaguely remember this I vaguely
remember this
all right
I remember it I remember it oh God I'm
dying I'm dying I'm why can't I not hit
you well that went terribly
uh
interesting this is indeed a house of
nightmares
lights are flashing don't
don't don't
interesting
fascinating all right
they made some improvements here
they made some improvements
oh
okay well that was fun
footy steps
who was that
hello hey
got him
hmm
someone there
oh interesting
the least efficient way I could have
gone in there
all right
uh do I break this
um
oh
oh
oh oh oh
oh thank you
right
uh
oh
man these lights are
flashing a little hard oh I remember I
remember now I remembered way too late
to remember anything important but I
remember
I think I remember dying on that oh I
remember I need to save more
who is you
who's you show yourself
oh here comes the nightmare of the house
oh no
hello
oh I can't move
oh well all right
whoa weird
kind of like oh this always reminded me
of Cry of Fear right which is another
game that I don't I wouldn't mind
hello
oh no
I'm gonna be demonetized
I'm being demonetized
that's what I said that's what I meant
Wham a boom a bangy
none of you like not many of you are
gonna understand that
but it was so weird that my brain wanted
to go to the same place that's
ah anyway great stuff
yep but oh
God you're gross
and these things are actually just from
Half-Life and man they are when you
really look at them they're just creepy
oh
all right hello
all right oh God
don't do it don't do it yeah that's what
I thought
huh
you guys are
getting kind of tough I don't remember
this game lasting this morning because
this is this is basically a remake of
Nightmare House one and Nightmare House
one was included in Nightmare House two
as far as as I think that's what that
was something behind me I doubt it yeah
he's coming in front of me
all right
oh where'd you go there was some behind
me
oh
it just sounds so awful
Wham
save Mark okay you're right save me
oh
I'm fine
good even great even
uh
interesting
um well it's fascinating because I don't
remember them doing Reflections in
Half-Life the engine what okay whatever
hello
stop that don't do that
oh I missed it do it again
please do that
oh
well this is cumbersome
do I jump it whoa
oh don't like the pit
save more God I should save more I never
save enough but then again I get like
real [ __ ] with my saves after a while
okay thank you
uh what hello oh
fine by me
I missed it do it again I literally
looked away at the wrong time do it
again
also how's the uh
how's the volume
good
you scare us taxes never stop saving
you're right
William I just turned it up I think it
needs to be higher where's the only fans
I haven't made it yet oh
I haven't made it yet I'm going to
it's a little low okay I I increased it
I increased it it can't just be my voice
try me try me
you tried and you failed me
try me
try me I'm sure you're giving me a lot
of Amro
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no this is not the right gun for this
there we go
well uh save all right
all right good stuff good stuff hi happy
Halloween
man you guys are kind of tough
yeah boy
my boy
oh I can get out why did I ever come in
oh I'm free oh [ __ ]
what the hell
where's my my shootie button like my
shootie dot goes away for some reason
I don't know why
who's there no stop
like my shooty DOT you know my shooty
DOT this is Nightmare House two
the classes
it uh really sparked my fear of
mannequins and uh you'll know why later
on in the game
well I made it I'm Gonna Save because
I'm clearly free
oh you're right I should have just run
God I'm gonna run
I'm making it I'm maiding it I made it
oh hey
I didn't make it
you can't escape
you can't escape from The Nightmare
you can't escape
you can't escape from The Nightmare
House
I made it I don't think I made it
oh surprise the game's not over this is
this is prologue
you only saw the prologue same as it
always was isn't it who the hell are you
just keeps sending you back again
even I familiar
familiar wake up it's time for the real
nightmare to begin okay
the real nightmare everybody
that was not Nightmare House two
fool you fool
experience begins
but yeah why was that
that voice was very familiar
why have I heard that before anyway
[Music]
chapter one rebirth who's mine
I never finished Amnesia rebirth many
people don't know why
[Music]
please remain calm and wait for further
assistance
okay sure whatever many people don't
know why
but some of you do and I'm sure that
some of you who do will be able to tell
those that don't what the reason is
and that way they're left festering in a
mystery it's loud in here
oh that that noise is just horrendously
loud hello
it seems like I'm in prison for some
reason I don't know why
security alert rescinded lockdown
removed I don't remember any of this I
remember nothing
hello
do you want to get out of
[Music]
it
first we're going to need to get you
armed
my surprise waiting for you there
are either like meatloaf surprise
or a gun
I'm not really sure what would be more
fitting in the kitchen hi I saw you you
wanna play peek-a-boo with me
with I'll play peek-a-boo with your mind
I think that's exactly what she's doing
security alert
see to the cell detention area
immediately
y'all right in there
you you good you oh
you're not good
I don't know why I looked up as if it
was like just a [ __ ] rocket launched him
into the ceiling or something I just
felt like looking up was the only
natural uh conclusion to make after that
one hmm all right okay
anywho
I'm gonna just go this way now cafeteria
right that's where I'm supposed to go
kitchen anybody's in the kitchen over
here
um cafeteria hi I'm hungry rev up those
Friars because I am sure hungry for
um
I remember this
flashback
um Lacey is not here editing so I have
to flash back
that thing flashback to me 10 years ago
picking up that and being what that
reenacted
wait a minute
and that's the reenactment holy crap oh
my God
all right well I did that okay did you
know that this is the same Ax from
Damien
true don't look it up
no
stop that don't do that
ah
you know for all the things in the
kitchen that I expected to find it an ax
wasn't necessarily the first choice but
hey I'll take it
oh
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah hi yeah who's
Damien did I just see who's Damien oh
uncultured swine you know what's a
tragedy is well it's not necessarily
tragedy because I don't want to like
besmirch uh lician's work but me playing
the game that lyxian made of the uh mini
series Damien that was handcrafted has
more views than the original Damien it's
just so so sad so sad
it's so sad by almost like twice as many
it's kind of nuts
hello
I wish we could continue this
okay thank you how did you do that also
how did you know that your ax was in the
kitchen and not know how it got there
how did you know it in the first place
hi
all right
we
I love vents
I love crawling in Vince
am I supposed to oh
hi whoa hey whoa hey whoa I was getting
there
I was getting there
I was getting there what do you think
that I'm I'm bad at games you need to
hold my hand through this no
I know what I'm doing
it's blurry increased quality I fix your
[ __ ] what are you talking about I can't
make it any more blurry get a better
internet connection stop watching at 144
p and click it up to a higher quality
I'm blasting this out at you at 1080 60.
glorious beautiful frames what happened
to my eyeballs
that's probably fine
this definitely isn't a recipe for
something terrible going on stop
bullying them what if they deserve to be
bullied have you ever considered that
what if they deserve it
I believe this is called the thickness
this is a security checkpoint and
inspection is required to proceed past
this area
please remain calm and await the nearby
security staff
[Music]
no no I'm gonna go with no
well I saw that
I saw that one
eyeball [ __ ]
try me try me all of you any of you
literally any of you try me
will show you the best time oh
oh oh oh oh oh
hi
good
result we're cut off
all around
I've heard that they're sending him
explain everything
that's probably not good oh
interesting oh we'll come closer
I'm waiting
what was that what'd you say
what'd you say to me
you say something
whisper it in my ear
all right shy
well we'll fix that hello my name is
Markiplier
why do they always run away when I say
that
anyway
um
what
save Ah that's probably right I saved I
saved I've been saving I've been saving
I've been saving
anyway chapter two exposure which is
another good name for my only fans
more more specifically I did it for
exposure which would be another good
name for my only fans
Dr Romero saved ice I am saving I am
saving I am doing the save the save is
what's happening
save Dave you know
that slogan
uh
raw donging and at 1 44 P I don't know
if you sound proud of that statement no
part of that you should be proud of oh
seems like a little too many explosions
for an elevator going down but what do I
know yeah you should not be proud of
that
does that make 1080 60 the equivalent of
wearing a condom I don't think so fix
your analogies before you fix yourself
hi
where am I going
radiology department
I I swear to God I was not reacting
earlier to that I thought of something I
am just so good at horror games I see
the Spooks coming before they even
happen
I know I timed that turn around
perfectly or it seemed like it but in
reality I'm pretty sure it was just I
turned around and then it would happen
it was meant to do that I am not that
guys I'm not that good guys jeez oh man
hope Hospital
we're taking great care to ensure the
comfort and Tranquility of our patients
you can find vending machines and
television sets in all waiting areas
please enjoy them as you wish
don't get up
all right
now that we work that out don't get uh
don't get up
oh here you got up oh I didn't tell you
before I wonked you
all right
well I can't exactly enjoy these Ben
machines branding machines
oh yeah flash warning there is a lot of
flashing lights in this game apparently
like now
I know it seemed like I can see into the
future but guys
I swear I can't
hold on
let's all right
I don't know if I will be able to do
that I don't know if I'll be able to do
that for some reason in my mind I
remember this being
equipment thank you
for some reason I I remember this
section of the game being at the end
when I played it 10 years ago so long
ago when I was just a weebab a wee baby
before I become jaded I guess the
horrors of the world
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I don't know that was really funny to me
oh [ __ ]
I don't know what that was
I apologize I need to treat this more
seriously
okay
okay um I seem to remember there being a
shotgun somewhere around here don't know
why they kept bullets on the bed oh this
is like someone's last meal just a
box oh
now come on now
I'm crying am I crying no I mustn't be
crying
you're the one who's crying all right
scared her oh
all right
probably gonna be in trouble at some
point here
all of my sassing is eventually going to
get to me is this gonna suck my gun to
it and there's a magnet
I'm having a flashback
I remember
[Music]
let let let me Ax no it's not time for
that yet no no not
no
no it's not time everybody hush let me
hush hush everybody
don't you remember Markiplier highlights
don't you remember don't you remember
Markiplier highlights you should have an
encyclopedic knowledge of the 5 000 some
odd videos on my channel
don't you remember don't tell me you
don't remember
how could I not remember
uh was I supposed to go here I don't
even remember I need a few
this way
of course you remember I'm not talking
about Happy Wheels highlights that's
completely different experience I'm
talking about
different highlights
oh
but please
fine
isn't there another way to get in here
nope
you got a fuse can I have a few
perfect oh that's not good better be
timed out
[Applause]
I'm gonna ask you a question what did
you just die
I don't even get to ask a question
oh no I'm good thank you where did My
Views go oh my
yeah I missed you ducked
take one of these oh okay
all right I seem to be swinging a little
high let me ask you a question let me
ask you you smell bad you should put on
some my jokes were terrible back then
why did anybody watch me my jokes are
not better now I don't even think I
qualify as telling jokes I think I think
my humor is 100 bully based oh oh my God
I'm gonna die I've not saved
oh
my God
all right anyway Let's uh uh let's make
more mistakes here we go
ah whoa ah oh I'm almost dead
oh
well five health is uh just as good
okay why did I do why why did I do that
why would anybody have done that
is that a penis
can I get out of here can I crawl
through here thank you
well
better save it five Health that's gonna
go well for me that's gonna go real good
for me
all right
let
me want me is that what you said
hope it's not
hold on
all right
[Music]
nurse
you all right
there's there's there's there's sir
sure
interesting ah all right do you think
that a hospital might have a bit more
thank you
I got a bad feeling about this
only fans coming out I have no idea
when it's going to be coming out but I
don't want to wait too long to do it
because I gotta
I mean I'm I'm in incredible shape as it
is but I have to take the pictures and
edit them and secure a URL
is it's a lot I have to do that I did
not do in advance because I did not
was 100 sure if I'd have to do it
out in a gun close
ah all right I saved thank you uh
but uh
so uh well oh one shots if I do I just
gotta aim low
all right
unlocking the main doors what are the
main doors why is it so Blinky blonky in
here
anybody can tell me did I just see
something run by where the main doors
where are the main doors
30 health I saved at five I will save
whenever I feel like it and whenever you
tell me the game is Nightmare House
two for those of you who don't know
this door is messed up
something not right with the door oh
frick you come back here you oh who's
being a little Silly Billy you come on
back here don't run away from me oh
don't be shy I don't bite
unless his age he's uh I can't my jokes
are bad now am I doing more darker wire
I don't even know who that is remember
this is 2012. I don't I darkiplier
didn't exist at this point just an
ethereal com con concept unless you're
talking about like don't blink and don't
move which those don't count what did I
just see
is that an ocean of blood
recalled iron law anybody
ah the good old hallucinations yeah
that's what some people call them
something like that
ethereal what
don't forget to promote the the chat
went by so fast I didn't see what I was
supposed to promote was I supposed to
promote something I probably forgot to
promote something what did I forget to
promote
I'm a terrible YouTuber and an even
worse streamer and I don't know why
anyone puts up with anything that I do
what was that
was that a skeleton
and visitors into its maintenance
sections only trained members of Staff
untrained staff or patients entering
these areas run the risk of
electrocution severe burns coughing fits
and potential limb loss please turn away
now
yes I am talking about you
well who is
but is this just a general message that
you recorded for everybody walking in
here what if uh what if someone actually
belongs to be in here you know for all
the business that clearly occurs here
you know
the business
all of it
huh
am I supposed to shrink myself down and
crawl into here is that what I'm
supposed to do oh oh I got oh
boom a bang
nice I'm a genius I
technically
could have done that before grabbing the
bullets but I'm still way too smart for
everybody in this game
you're saved why who why
do you know that I don't know
what do you mean I've lost
you want something from you
oh that's right
that's right
everyone behind the third washing
machine that's right I forgot what I
what was right I've completely forgot
what I was going to say because I get
distracted by everything else that was
occurring
but that's right
whatever it is
you're
what what about your UC what did you
just say to me what what
anyway Urban behind the third washing
machine can I move this oh I don't need
to move it I don't need to move anything
I'm good just the way I oh
I was not scared let's go to save I'm
gonna move on I heard something usy and
given how much everyone on the internet
likes to put Lucy on the end of things
they're just slapping their [ __ ] all
over the place
I am inclined to believe that that's
what I heard that's what my ears have
been trained to hear the AI model of my
brain just sees Lucy everywhere
it's just the way it is I'm trying to
get in that only I'm trying to get the
only Fan's grind set please uh excuse
you don't question the way my mind is uh
focused right now oh I remember this
place don't remember there being bullets
before
is a different place
conclusion is not I'm in the same place
and there are now bullets it's that I am
in a different place which has bullets
Bang
just in case
all right what am I doing
well that's spooky I get it never lose
hope NH Nightmare House
it die oh
many bad things happened in once
all right fine
[Applause]
oh
that did nothing
why did that do that
well that did something
why did that do something and the other
thing did nothing
hardly seems fair
oh smash
smack oh
I remember that man if I'd have been a
five Health that would have been very
bad
but I got smacked all right foosay
oh yeah
huh nope
is this not right I feel like this is
right unless it only goes in a specific
spot
it do
that it do okay so my mistake was
to being born or something I don't know
something hilarious ah interesting
okay you
well those those flares really did me a
lot of good I'm glad I put them to just
such good use
and Wham okay and Wham
what am I turning on
I don't have the foggiest clue
oh I'm being pulled towards it
no I'm not I accidentally pressed the
forward button
I thought
I thought I was being pulled towards
that I I my finger leaned on the forward
button
um
oh my God stop stop stop stop stop stop
what are you what are you wondering what
even are you God oh my God
stop stop don't don't don't hey cut you
uh oh oh I'm about you I'm about to oh
I'm about to oh you oh God stop don't do
that oh yeah oh there you go that's what
you get
that's what I thought that was weird
never seen one of those before don't
know what that was all about can I get
through it
please
all right save I'm saving
I'm saving I am doing the saving
I'm saving
videos 2 HD lowered to 144p I don't
think I can do that
I don't think I can do that if you want
to watch this at 144p that is your
prerogative that's not mine that's not
mine you must lower the quality on your
end
I will not do that I have certain
standards
I believe in good quality I believe
incredible quality I am saving I'm
saving hope you stop slapping me
how many more slaps how many I can't see
okay can you stop with the blinking oh
what oh what I ca I can't see
I can't see
oh I'm not gonna stick around for that
who in the hell was the why
saving
country internet sucks well that's good
for you I don't have it
although I do wish I had better internet
foreign
I do wish I had better internet that
would be lovely but I don't
all my life the only thing I've ever
wanted was a Fiber Optic internet
connection and yet do I have it no
I don't
what I would do
dude for I would
I
would
I would if I hadn't promised the only
fans money to charity I would spend it
to get Fiber Optic internet but I'm a
man of my word
and I shall not do that I have integrity
and I don't even think I could
that's the thing he's like why can't I
why can't you just why isn't it a thing
where you're just like
I want to get internet here is money
give me internet why don't I have it
because it's not available where I is
okay it's not it's just the way it works
I don't know I don't get it any of you
work in the internet world I don't
understand it I understand it perfectly
I just choose I refuse to understand it
I refuse
you have one gigabit internet mirrored
for 70 a month that's so good for you
that's so oh I'm so happy
pushing the water there
if it did I didn't notice it
and it wasn't important because I did
not
who's doing something in the water over
there
someone having a good time
whoa my God it was too hot you okay are
you all right
you okay
oh no
all right anybody up for a shower well
you know it killed that guy but I'll try
it
that's nice
anyway
no what
you tricked me
you tricked me you tricked me I
hello I saw that
okay
I don't like being tricked
I don't like being tricked at all
I wonder what would happen like how low
do you think I could get the quality no
I did that I did that I am so many steps
ahead of you guys I literally did a
stream
where I tried to stream at the lowest
quality possible unless that's what
you're referring to but I don't think it
is I think that you think that you have
ideas that I have not already had
it's so hard making history every day
the crowd screams and they scream for me
come back here come back here
and they scream for me
Glory comes it's such a heavy price oh
hello oh
I don't know why it's so slow
oh
are you
what do you think you're doing
what do you think you're doing
sweet
I don't see him I can smell your bones
oh you silly cow
interesting
I guess I just go in the vent I'm pretty
sure that's just what I do save you got
it I didn't oh there we go saved perfect
oh where am I is this still the hot oh
is this still the hospital
is this is this a hospital is this a
hobby
this is horrible
this is a hospital
oh no
uh
interesting
I remember you yeah uh this is one of
the earliest things I've ever
encountered that did this thing
this thing right here
ah it's not good
uh
uh not good
called not good
oh yeah that's right oh my God
oh yeah oh I remember now
okay not received all right
what
why am I having flashbacks to my
childhood you ask
I was an adult when I played this I know
it seems from my early videos that I was
some prepubescent
boy but I was a man and I was a man who
played very scary games
as only a man or I suppose anyone of any
gender could
so don't judge me
wasn't my childhood
I was an adult
I am a kid no I'm an adult
[Music]
yeah I kind of forgot for a second you
were like you guys are just salivating
over the glory that is 144p if you
require any assistance please contact a
nurse at the nearest nursing station for
more information
like I know you guys are just rabid for
the save button and glorious
144p but when you say you're part of the
8p club it sounds like something else
I mean maybe you should be proud of
being part of the 8p club but I mean
just God can you beat the glory that is
144p
oh what the hell what in the hell
watching the hell
hello
[Music]
[Music]
frick
oh God
why
that
I'm fine apparently
[Music]
8p Club Make Some Noise you know you go
for whatever you got you go for what you
have to take a minute of your time to
notify you
know
everybody
[Music]
there was something
you were right
the news there the news there I knew it
was there I knew I knew all along it was
there I knew 100 it was there I might
have inhaled
I'm fine
saving
well it doesn't access to private rooms
of patients in this section is
prohibited without proper authorization
please contact the named ask for details
and booking Arrangements
I really want to go in here
someone's rocking 4p wow
one p gang negative one Peak
virgin 4K versus Chad 8p
oh man yeah you don't even know what
okay that is the next question
what would a 144p stream look like
because I've done low bit rate and it
turns out you can stream at like 25 bits
per second which does not get a good
image however
what is the lowest resolution that you
can possibly stream at that's a question
that I want to know
see those headshots you see them
oh my God how are you moving without
your head
oh
one by one pixel I don't even know what
would that be it would just be a
changing color that's all it would be if
you streamed it one pixel it would just
be the color would change that's it
that's all the indication you would ever
know that something's happening who just
left who Do You Think You Are
what oh did they just drop off SWAT
there's
oh
that that ain't right
oh
hey where do you think you are
the doctors why
hey again with that thing that I saw
what's his sound what what's his sound
what what is sound what what is sound
what is uh why no no don't what no no
did I miss something is there why who's
crying who in this stream is crying
right now you all can't be crying no
sniveling no crying there's a very toxic
stream yeah I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
stand for that I'm not standing for it
I hear crying who is sniveling out there
who is just being a little baby in the
face of all this Danger
we
grown up together okay I'm not saying I
was a child when I started this I was an
adult I want to make that very clear
shut up who's crying oh
it's not me
oh God I can't show that on stream God
I'm gonna get demonetized
ah yes SWAT has arrived
it's not because I'm trying to be mean
against people crying you can show your
emotions however it's because the people
that are crying are often terrifying and
horrifying and ready to lash out
so don't be there it's yeah shaking and
crying RN yeah you should be but don't
or something I have no idea someone just
said help me and I don't know why
ah you smacked me
who the frick smacked me
oh no
oh oh
no oh interesting
fascinating
what what what did you say to me what
did you what
I was yeah I was never a child I want
everyone to know this
wasn't a I came out the womb and adult
okay with like a a
what a freaking 401K already or no
what's the tax form I don't even know
but I'm an adult I swear I know what
taxes are I've definitely paid my taxes
okay don't question me I've done taxes
which I have
more and I know the forms you got your
you got your 1080s and your
480.
case
I know all about taxes
yeah the the
W one WD-40 yep yep WD-40 I know oh crap
what was happening
oh that's not good all right this is not
good everybody
I'm alive
hello
okay
how do you know that
yeah I do yes
let's be buddies
okay
hi friends ah you're very strong you
must
he must okay
all right you you seem like you know
your way around here do you mind taking
Point don't worry we'll cover you
I don't mind because I'm brave and I'm
an adult and I am a grown-up and I will
conquer this
I don't know
that's what we need to find out
I always did think this is kind of cool
because you do have your like it is like
a
h
zombie do you guys encounter zombies a
lot I think it was pretty cool
I think it's pretty cool
I should probably let them do the work
but again I'm very brave very
responsible
good god
look out
okay how did
sector clear yeah kind of okay so where
do I go I'm kind of confused
these rooms oh
I see
oh what
what is that
what is and was that
hello
thank you
Cry of Fear oh no no no no no no
no no no no oh no no no this excuse me I
know you all want to shower with me but
it's fine
it's weird I don't think your message is
working correctly
but what was I gonna say you can't I
keep getting distracted I have no idea
oh
oh
Johnson
Johnson cool
oh
I'll take it oh God look at your hands
oh God please help me
clearly I need support okay well I'm
barely bad I did I did
I thought I did
I'm trying my best these bullets don't
seem to actually work very well
like no other no one of you guys are
dying here literally these bullets do
very little
duh they're going after me which is
great thank you for all the help I have
two Health all right
I'm alive
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna hide in
this corner I bet I bet I'm gonna be
fine if I just let them do all the work
whoa
they really like me
I'm trying man I'm trying okay I got
this I'll save in between so I can
actually do this I have a funny feeling
that when I played this originally uh I
also died many a Time
oh
help help help help help
[Music]
my bang
are we not why not
okay I'm moving
oh God why did you guys not fall in the
pit
okay
whatever you say pal thank you pal
thank you very much
where's lexian I don't know lexian's not
helping me here kind of on my own I
might be on my own now
you just joined what's happening welcome
to Nightmare House 2.
It's a Wonderful game that was
remastered in 2015 that I have not
played in about 10 years
this is great
give lyxian is two dollars I don't know
if it is I do know that Faith chapter 3
is out I am aware of that and it is on
my list I
oh mercy
pyrotechnic Locker
oh oh God
oh my flashlight's gone
oh my flat
oh my flashlight's gone
oh no
oh
no
okay
interesting
so uh I I this is on my list of things
to play and it is there and yes I have
confirmed that and only fans will occur
so don't you worry about that let me
worry about that
but I don't know exactly when but it
won't be too terribly long
all of you thirsty bastards will get
everything that's coming to you in due
time so do not worry
everything is as it should be
um
good good I'm here now
oh
Frick hey hey no
holy crap
I slapped you into next year
no no no no no no no no I think you're
dead
I can't see [ __ ]
I'm down here now
oh God I can't see [ __ ] oh god oh oh oh
hey
is there zombies
zombies down here what's happening I
can't see anything what's happening
okay oh my God holy crap no you don't oh
walk into me walk into my Jack
oh frick oh I'm where am I got him got
him got him
what
that's right you're dead is there
another okay I see the door this
how
oh don't the whole man I [ __ ] Wonka
[ __ ] flunked you
okay good I just gotta make this jump oh
don't do that to me
huh
can you see chica no
no
no
no no there's there's no there's no way
there is no
yeah okay you can
oh okay
five ten oh
all right I accept this I accept it I
will accept it this is as it should be
I will take this upon myself
all right thank you
thank you for that for checking I
appreciate it
come on move move damn it move what move
move oh
there we go
oh thank you for that I'll just take
that no I won't apparently
all right thank you for that
let's see chica I don't know why I
should
you know I'm seriously why should I give
me one good reason why I should let you
shoot you
do you deserve it do you deserve it I
don't think you have when's the last
time you played petting chica simulator
huh when's the last time you did that I
don't think it's been very recently also
this isn't working
strangely enough
so uh you know you can't really say oh I
see it's not working because I wasn't
supposed to go that way
hey I just swatted my flare away I hope
this is the newer one or I'm gonna be
screwed
oh good thank you
huh you will well
oh no you don't
do this to me
don't do this to me ah nah ah no okay so
now we're finally back at the part that
scarred me for life
really solidified my fear of mannequins
we're gonna see if this [ __ ] is still
just as scary in 2022 as it was in 2012.
okay here we go never mind
hi it's this guy
oh there's a helicopter
surgery area correct
you know you can curse
just so you know I just want you to know
that
crew you
you I still don't like it I don't like
it
I really it's some it just makes my skin
curl
I don't like it I don't like them I
don't like them at all
I don't like any part of them
oh take that
oh here we go
oh
[Laughter]
yeah I'm gonna smack you back
I'm a smack oh
boy
Jake that and one for you and another
for both of you never mind
I don't like them the rest of you will
live on as an example what are you doing
short stuff
shrimpy
there you looking at me
what are you doing you looking at me
oh
warm what are you doing here shrimping
are you doing Chuckles you laughing at
me you laughing at me
you're laughing at me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
interesting
dude what dude but the thing is I don't
want to I'm gonna freaking
good this looks like the lab from Heist
God
look at that
I don't like it
I don't like any of this I don't like it
I'm going to go ahead and say that I
don't like it
I don't like it at all
don't like it I hate
you know what I want to play you know
what I want to play instead of horror
games you know what who thought horror
games for October who thought of that I
want to play Oxygen not include you know
I want to do like a big 24-hour stream
of me doing nothing but oxygen not
included you know I just want to do that
I just want to do who are you you
mannequin I'll smack you yeah okay yeah
okay oh sure
yeah oh you can't talk oh it's weird
what are you pointing at
again over there you want me to go over
there
played oxygen not included in a very
long time and I've never been good at
the game I've literally never gotten to
the point of sustainability and that's a
problem and I don't like that but
someday I
someday I will
I'm fine whatever
oh
should I have done that should I have
done that
no no
hmm
I will never trust again
I'll never trust again
I'll never trust again I'll never trust
again
I'll never trust ever ever again
even though I should have known
that's a lot of blood
that's there's a lot of blood
I said look I've gone blind
hello
that's a lot of blood
I'm proud of you
you okay
all right
nothing to be done about that
there is something to be done about you
dodged ah who stopped that's what you
get
now this this makes sense to me this I
can manage
this is okay
saving
now that there's no more mannequins
getting in the way
now I can get on with a real business
what about the nurses what about what do
I need to do nurses
uh-huh
tell me about all the people you've
helped here
what are they did you guys see what did
you see was that the gun reloading or
what was it what was the deal with that
what was the deal with that
what if they did all my streams like
this oh my god oh I'm boned
I might be bound
uh
try me
excellent
would you prefer this
this is for only events
I should play sea of Thieves I haven't
played that in a very long time I never
got into it because mostly I'm not too
big in competitive multiplayer
experiences I'm dying
but uh
no I will make it only fans I haven't
made it yet I will make it I will make
it I will make it only fans
I haven't made it yet but you guys met
my requirements or whatever I called
them
criteria I had a good word for him I
never know half the things I say or do
so it's really a mystery just to me as
well of what comes out of my mouth
so I can't really speak for anything
like that Bang Bang
because Woods really resistant to
bullets
give a preview I haven't what do you
want me to get naked right now then my
channel would be banned and then all
this would be for moot
there wouldn't be anything for you to
see I'd be I'd be gone I'd be I'd break
TOS I would get demonetized out of
existence
can't have it done can't be done can't
be done cannot be done how do I turn
this down
okay
hmm interesting
hmm
seems like I throw in something in there
to blow it up maybe
oh
how convenient
hope
it went for a good measure then
yeah two points a Wham I said
no
is This I Swear
I I don't think that I'm wrong here
ready
oh
console is locked find another way to
shut it down
i i oh
a couple minutes
uh you better get out of there the whole
place is on fire
yeah
thanks yeah fine whatever shut up the
fire is hot everybody the fire is hot oh
my God holy [ __ ]
oh
don't oh God
well this is a problem oh
yeah this is not a drill
probably some East oh God
some Easter egg stuff through here but
who knows oh my God that was close
oh no
save me someone please
please
well I'm dead
oh thank you
thank you for that
you saved me oh
I guess I go this way
how much is my only fans going to cost I
have no idea
I have no idea how much they I don't
know the first thing about only fans
how much does it normally cost
because it's going for charity it'll go
for charity and I'll probably contribute
a lot of my own money to charity as well
uh whatever the charity would
pick
but uh I should say
oh
it's okay
just see all cat hi
oh hi
see all caps I'll pay anything please oh
was that my ribs
am I actually doing it am I actually
okay with it yeah why why is there
people hi
people assume something
very different
I'm real quick guys I'm really I'll sell
my life anything for the fact I'm on my
knees yes
hey you guys do that
I I sense the desperation
coming through
I sense the desperation
I did you you
they're good they're going to be taste
it's tasteful
do you know what tasteful means you guys
right now the behavior is not tasteful
I'm gonna say that straight up not
tasteful
it is a no
hey what's up you cash
grab the weapon oh you got it you got it
bruh
I got the weapons
Evac all right let's see vac where are
we backing to where's our vac point
yeah let me just tell you the Johnson
how did you know Johnson did did he seem
like the type of guy that had a lot of
blood
because I just want to say he doesn't
have that anymore
he's kind of like cut back on the blood
if you know what I mean so that's that's
how I found
yes
you should indeed
you guys need to get uh used to this
place
that's gross please stand clear okay
all right
let's do this boys what are we doing I
just don't think I'm supposed to throw
it in there
uh you're alive I knew it I knew it
dummy
all right
huh
interesting
so uh what am I supposed to do
Source engine game yes is Nightmare
House two the remastered version
I know right that's what makes it fun
do you babies get over it
don't worry guys I got it oh God I don't
have that one I don't have this one
the ax seems to work better than almost
any bullet does so I'm just gonna go ax
straight UPS oh get it take some of this
and one of these
I don't want to lose yeah the heavy
attack on this is better than anything
pretty good sell my soul it's happening
well I mean you do still have to pay for
it but it's happening don't worry about
it don't worry about it don't worry it's
happening I'm I keep my promises
now look I reserve the right to create
further incentives in the future for
said only fans
but for now it's going to be tasteful
yeah okay you you got it I guess I don't
know much of a choice
we
freak my promises what do you mean my
bro what's wrong with my promises what's
wrong with my promises
what's wrong with my promises
look at me
you'll become rich as Elon Musk uh it's
for charity thank you very much uh just
like my original tasteful news were for
charity this will also be for charity so
don't you worry about that
for charity
Pinky Promise what did I promise I don't
know what I promised what the further
incentive for even further tasteful
nudes
mayhaps mayhaps are could be
I have no idea
how much is it
no did you guys answer my question on
how much it normally is which would
expose which one of yous or all I mean
you've already been extremely desperate
but
each one of you
where am I going where are we going
where are we going
wait
that's where I came from
okay
I figured you you in swat would have
done that more than a few times
oh
what a boss
very close
hey cut that you you oh my God how did
you get on fire
foreign
oh my God I can't see anything in this
that's the thing about the source engine
is like there's no such thing as like
Global illumination or bounce light it's
all just pure directional light which is
fine it's an older engine but it's like
man I can't see anything it kind of also
lends to the creepiness in certain
aspects and other times it is
a little bit droll
the droll
all right well good for us we made it I
don't know where you guys are
will you hurry up then
hurry up and get over here
one two
[Music]
three
you okay
which charity I haven't picked yet I'll
probably just do the same thing I've
done before you either pick a charity
that I've uh raised for before or find a
Good Charity on uh that's highly
reputable through charity Navigator and
whatnot
huh what am I doing
is it me
yeah
would you want me
okay am I supposed to oh
I was in the morning I I was in the way
I was in the Blast Zone
that wasn't a blessing
thank you thank you very much
uh-huh what do you mean
who's staying with who him me am I him
who's him
oh no I'm going I'm not him
he's retiring soon
all right
now let's get back to the others
oh
control of yourself
the noise
why in the world is he talking
I don't know
oops
I don't know
could we have
could we have wait no I saved there hang
on
no no no not quit
wait no yes no yes no yes no
what happens if you don't do anything
that's real that's the real answer
that's 5D chest there
foreign
man I really just stood there and
watched that happen
there's nothing that I could have done
nothing I could have done
maybe if I use a less powerful weapon
somewhere I got this
well my aim's just too good
uh-huh
I uh I shot the gun guys that's just a
very big gun
oh well can't win them all
as well
whoa has a lot of blood
fin is that you're
saying you how'd you get all that blood
I I should know better yeah
I always slow you ain't doing nothing
okay ax is about to kill you by now okay
export to kill you by now okay I was
about to kill you by now ow
good God stop it
got it okay maybe there's not as good as
I thought it was for some reason I think
I just pulled it out when I was
finishing things off and that happened
to work out for me
doesn't work out anything
oh God
all right I'll clear good job
axis Superior weapon of choice uh well
in this game it's all all the weapons
are kind of wimpy
just a little bit windy
I don't know if you've aged any further
in the last few minutes but uh I don't
know about getting too old for this [ __ ]
at all
uh sure
oh that's not good that's not good
oh
okay well that's what you get for
holding your breath I guess for catching
it or holding
we we got this buddy man they did not
die at all why didn't they not die I
don't know why am I not using this gun
oh come on why is everything so wimpy
since when do bullets do so little
oh my God
how the Earth does not work a egg
how I'm sorry I I'm sorry
fine
oh don't do it
don't
don't do it no
all right
you're not supposed to fight well I
tried to get by him but they just keep
whapping me they keep whapping me and
then they're coming down the stairs what
am I supposed to do I got I I don't know
they're just in the way I
oh
no he's saying shoot you're all telling
me not to fight you're being ridiculous
okay you don't know what you're talking
about
these guys are just real tough they're
I'm a very good player of games and
these guys are just guys
they're just up
um buddy pal
palpati
see you're supposed to shoot him
reach what one how do you even know
there's one up here you've got psychic
abilities don't you Commander
I see through your lies
all right
uh
I'm on the way
hahaha
oh nice
uh sir
friend your help again
foreign
there we go
I miss having the other guys here I
think they were marginally better at
killing than you
hello
this is gonna go wonderfully
oh stop talking
but it looks so cool it's so cool
ow
well
that didn't work out so well for me
foreign
interesting seems that everyone is dead
[Music]
them for a while now some things happen
here people wouldn't
think
it's covered however not so long ago
they detected something
nice
what's wrong with you
uh-huh so this Dr Romero I see I see he
was the villain all along
I was a fool I Was a Fool how could I do
this
dude dude stop now
Alpha I am not a murderer I have never
intentionally killed anyone and I don't
plan on starting tonight all right
murderer says what I want to give you
murderer says therefore
murderer says main level
if you're bound to determine to finally
kill me though just keep heading down
the elevator I won't stop you from
coming just be warned I will be forced
to defend myself I mean you know it
sounds like a good deal and I believe
you 100
um but
oh man I could leave can I leave I'm
alone oh come on
now I'm leaving
hope you had a pleasant and an enjoyable
stay
don't go out
never low never hope a hospital
all right I'm out of here I'm freaking
free
not my problem oh hey
hey
why'd you do that
hey
what's wrong with you
wow
my dick
you've chosen to escape your fate and
paid the price
you can't escape the nightmare you can't
you mustn't you shouldn't you chance you
shouldn't you went you won't
all right fine
whatever I'm getting it I'm getting it
Radiology where where am I going I don't
even know where I'm going where do I go
I I'm not going there where do I go oh
element
I remember
I remember
this area is restricted to senior level
staff only
if you do not have the proper
authorization please leave immediately
no I have it
it's from my own Goods
you don't even know I don't need lady
whoever is the announcer person I don't
know if you're consistent on anything
that you say ever oh it's so bright here
core results
man okay doc Dr Romero I gotta say
you're uh
sketches
not the best
okay
but uh they get the point across I
suppose all right well doc uh I'm gonna
you know uh break everything I can hear
the elevator there on their way down
here I just hope the whole thing won't
break the moment I start it I can hit
the door there here I just have to I
just have to talk you have to talk what
you have to talk
ta
uh okay
uh
this makes sense
makes a lot of sense
makes a lot of sense looks familiar I
get it this is where he was talking to
me
I get it
so what do I do how do I blow this [ __ ]
up I don't remember how do I blow it up
I'm here to blow it
let me blow it God this is such a this
whole thing has been like such a trip
because it is it is like
it's weird because it's memories right
you know it's just like I've done all
this before so it was this weird feeling
of deja vu but it's been a very long
time since I have done this
and like kind of the beers like this is
one of the earliest games that I played
definitely one of the beginnings of me
starting down a rabbit hole of playing
horror games specifically I like to be
ears
that's funky oh God
because it's like I wouldn't think I
would remember this as much as I do but
I do remember a lot of it
ah don't remember that
this is the core my life's long work
beautiful isn't it it's important to me
and I'll go as far as needed in order to
achieve my goals I made some mistakes
sacrifices my loved one and even I
myself that I have to
there is no turning back now
I'm afraid I can't let you interfere
it's protecting me you see keeping me
safe from her therefore I have to send a
few friends to keep you company okay see
how long you last against them that's
always a great experiment always
what oh why you gotta send these
bull
all right let's see if I actually got
what it takes to not suck
I'm just gonna quick save after every
single kill
it's the only way that I can know
you're having fun yeah you know me oh
wait I'm supposed to do something I
remember
uh
what the hell are you doing well even
with 50 of the power the Court's still
fully functional anymore
all right I actually wasn't planning on
using no choice the what
oh
interesting
from up here just let me recharge it for
a bit and I'll make sure you get a
headset today
okay so there's got to be something else
to this to oh boy oh that's not that bad
there's got to be something else oh hi
that's where you are I wonder
okay so there's got to be something to
do I definitely remember what it is that
was probably just a clue that got
whispered into my brain
yeah
but you're welcome no there's a way I am
going to kick your ass with science of
course
science yes oh I see it these are ah I
got it I got it
I see
uh I need the ax that's what it is
oh God that's why it's pushing me out of
this thing
I also can do this all day
man
there we go
there maybe it doesn't I I feel like
bullets don't work very good against the
destructible stuff
but it is one way to consistently get
hits on them
maybe it needs maybe yeah it's better
style points anyway
oh
come on oh my God
he's gonna be a pain in the ass I gotta
swing back around for like some more
health or something or else I'm just
gonna wind myself down
oh God
there we go
are they
weird
come on
you'd think that if I'm just swinging an
ax it would actually swung into things
oh I got this I got it
I I'm gonna get it oh God come on
yeah there we go that's good
no no no no
I need help oh God I need help
I need help oh God I need help where's
Health yes I got health
ow maybe I should maybe I should stand
directly under it Liz
oh it's I've got to be able to shoot
these things I just gotta oh you shut up
shut up
more health I need it
good
oh
my God
no
God
you don't know how many friends I have
you don't know what I do you don't know
who I am
I'm Markiplier [ __ ]
yeah uh-huh funny about that I'm not
gonna let you keep doing that time to
send you somewhere else in your own head
bon voyage
huh interesting you can do that oh
oh God that's a problem
oh
that can't be she can't
beer
stop it you can't even imagine what will
happen if this whole thing Falls I am
trying to imagine
oh come on
oh come on
oh
whoa
round two or what
round two or what run run round two of
what
oh God oh God oh man I gotta get him so
they get pushed away from this side
otherwise I'm just gonna be in trouble
every time
around
this is a little tedious everybody this
is a little tedious
oh my God are you serious
whoa hey I'm trapped no don't no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
out okay it's fine
yeah good night
oh thanks
all right
oh
foreign
oh
God no no it was me all along
it was you oh
this feels like you just feel like some
kind of look at a meme video just boom
I can't save I'm trying to save you see
I hit I hit the save button it don't
save it just don't save
they don't save anything
it'll save
oh please
I'm Gonna Save oh I'm saving I have
eight health oh my god
oh no I'm Dr Romero
[Music]
in front of our house by accident and
ended up here it's not a coincidence
not a bad person is more complicated
than you'll ever understand
what makes you think you will uh does ax
oh God
whoa
uh
this one I'll try
ow ow okay well oh my God please oh let
me live let me live
huh she saved me from that one
she's everything you want
she's
everything you want this
this ghost lady is everything
you've ever wanted
ah hello
hi
how are you good hello good day
so I I get picked up from an explosion
and you just send me right into a padded
cell
ah this is one freaking thing left
oh my God just please please shoot it
swing got it
that's it that's it
I did it I broke a thing it's gone
forever I did it
hey yay
well what do you know
it's still operative
I guess I won
oh
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
back
I'm sorry for everything that's happened
I'm sorry for everything I had
ah
how are you still alive
oh you're welcome
oh you're welcome
oh yeah Yahoo
no but it does seem a lot like fear
right it does seem a lot like fear
like it is it is I I believe it's a lot
inspired from Fear if I'm not mistaken
it is very similar
um but this is one of the earliest games
that I've ever played so it is fun to be
able to play it again and especially the
re-uh reimagined version
so pretty good pretty good stuff so yeah
thank you guys so much I'm gonna get
back to regular videos uh starting
tomorrow
it's another one of the situations where
I have had videos ready but I've been so
busy with the edit of that thing I know
we're not going to talk about
um but it's it's um it's been very fun
I've been editing the edge of sleep TV
show and it's been we're helping at it
it's been very good
so seriously thank you guys so much uh
for
being all wonderful and whatnot and
helping enable me to start and only fans
which will happen in the very near
future so thank you I appreciate all of
you being here I appreciate you all
being patience while I finish up some
work that I needed to do otherwise the
only fans will be at some point in the
very near future and I'll get back to
the stuff that uh brought me to YouTube
in the first place
which is a lot of playing games making
videos for you which is at the core of
everything I do even though the
Ridiculousness of everything else comes
and goes
and only fans beat that as it may and
tasteful nudes be what they are
and your desperation Rings true I
appreciate you being here and allowing
me to do the things that I do so thank
you
have a lovely day
I'll be
back tomorrow thank you
and uh
as always
I'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye bye